il y à des villes ça est une ville
lumière une ville éternelle est une
ville phoenix varsovie pour ceux qui ont
vécu la dernière guerre mondiale
son nom n'est pas le premier sur la
liste des villes captive ou vienne et
prague le prince saoud
mais il est le premier à s'y inscrire en
lettres rouges rouges passif ronge marty
rouge brasier rouge sang qu'il
devinerait aujourd'hui devant la
jeunesse des visages des rues la montée
tranquille déplace la masse dominatrice
des bâtiments modernes qui donnerait à
penser que vous receviez sorti de la
tempête avec un supplément de
perspectives et un énorme surcroît étage
non
e
et pourtant quelle ville a plus souffert
c'est ici que la guerre a cessé d'être
une partie des scream diplomatiques
entre la massue d'hitler et le parapluie
de monsieur chamberlain pour devenir la
guerre totale celles qui ne voient sur
la terre que des objectifs militaires et
qui tuent indistinctement le civil et le
militaire
c'est ici qu'a commencé après
bombardements description occupation et
ratissage l' escalade de douleur qui
allait aboutir alors que l'allemagne
nazie avait d'ores et déjà perdu la
guerre aux deux plus grandes tueries
systématiques du siècle
l'anéantissement du ghetto
l'extermination des rangs de
l'insurrection
au milieu d'une boucherie de population
sans autre exemple en europe
des chiffres à quoi bon à varsovie le
tombeau du soldat inconnu pourrait être
un monument ou civil inconnu
après le massacre la ville n'était plus
90% de ses bâtiments avaient été
détruits soit 30 % de ce que l'on
appelle le feu de l'action et 60% de 100
francs par des commandos spécialisé dans
les caries sage des villes mortes et
munis de l'outillage nécessaire non
seulement pour abattre les murs mais
encore pour oblitérer le système nerveux
souterrain des cités modernes
bien entendu les édifices à caractère
historique sur l'objet d'un traitement
tout particulier de la part de ces
spécialistes de l'effondrement
quand on prétend écrire l'histoire
nouvelle pour milan on ne saurait
prendre trop de précautions contre
l'histoire ancienne
et puis la vie est revenue elle a
recommencé à couler dans les rues d
encombrer la ville pierre par pierre a
retrouvé son ossature
ses façades son visage
à
ouais
e
il dans cette ville un revenu lentement
à la lumière et qui a renoncé à compter
ses morts
que voulez vous que je joue la troupe du
théâtre national
si ce n'est un mystère médiéval sur le
thème de la résurrection
nissan souffre à nouveau programme ou
niqab ce vaste projet phare i go balades
à cheval
à
au bout de cette allée plantée dit-on
par le roi yan sobieski du temps que les
rois croyait avoir le temps de se
préparer un peu d'ombré sur la terre le
château il a neuf parle tout seul au
fond d'un immense jardin des bonheurs et
des malheurs de l'ancien pologne dans
les grandes salles du palais transformée
en musée on peut entendre résonner ne
pas impatiente naples et andy que se
glisse entre les armes
l'image légère et fugitive de marie
valeska rêvons
et rêvons encore dans le parc des
oiseaux qui tracé par les maîtres
jardiniers du roi stanislas homobus
poniatowski protecteur des arts et des
jolies femmes
qu'est-ce que varsovie
qu'est ce que la pologne
la réponse nous sera peut être donnée
par ce piano lointain écouter frédéric
chopin
c'est non loin de là dans cette maison
qu'il a écrit ses premières heures
atteint déjà par cette maladie mortelle
qu'on appelle le génie c'est là que l'on
a entendu pour la première fois égrené
dans la brume ces quelques notes
mélancoliques qui ne sortiront plus de
la mémoire des hommes
et c'est là que la pologne nouvelle
vient encore écouter parfois leur
étendue le murmure insistante ses
espérances éternel mais qui sait ce
qu'elle retiendra de ce nocturne apaisé
sur d'épouvantables souvenir
à